well hello reject nation it's Greg Alba
here right now I'm hiding in the coat
closet waiting for John to come home for
you guys who don't know John has been a
scare at Halloween Horror Nights for the
past two years so for the past two
months he's been living here I've been
pulling scare pranks on him to show him
who's boss every morning at 6 a.m. this
guy wakes up to take a piss
how do I know this because the damn fan
wakes me up every [ __ ] morning knock
you back with little [ __ ]
my man go take a piss
you take your phone so I just texted him
he said he'll be home any minute now I
left the camera recording in the living
room so you guys can see Greg Greg know
you're here dude so your car in the
garage
Wow
[Laughter]
dude I'm sick of this man this is like
the 10th day in a row you've made your
point do you just take a joke it's not
funny anymore man
you're making living here feel very
uncomfortable oh dude I'm sorry I didn't
I don't realize those hazy feeling come
here let me zoom the camera I'm sorry
hey dude yeah seriously I'm really sorry
I I know sometimes I could be an [ __ ]
and I usually realize like sooner than
later when I'm being an [ __ ] but this
time I really [ __ ] up you know best
friends for like 20-something years now
and we're finally living together and
just to be honest like the last thing I
want is for you to feel uncomfortable
and I don't know if I've ever thought
was being funny but I'm not I'm stuck
I'm sorry sorry you sure can we hug it
out hug it out yeah to pranks in one
video baby
[Music]
[Music]
hello Craig for years you have made
emotional connections with the ones you
love and for years who have used your
humor to sabotage those friendships
you're afraid of connection are you
afraid to love and to put it plain and
simple you don't appreciate your life no
I I share my sense of humor because I
love others no knowing how textbook you
can be I'm going to assume you'll try
and talk your way out of this one this
is a recording so don't waste your words
[ __ ] will find on that I wouldn't have
seen it the device strapped to your
penis will tear it off in 90 seconds
unless of course you play by my rules
and the rules are simple
the rules are always
I don't know why most people don't
survive my traps when the rules are
always so simple okay John I know this
is you John if you can get a complete
erection before the timer goes off the
device will unlock and you can continue
masturbating to the graphic pornography
you so often enjoy well actually I quit
watching porn a while ago I realized I
performed better in bed if I stopped
trying to talk this is a pre-recorded
video but the game begin hello no waste
your time trying to call anyone over the
phone i rewired it tell me receive
incoming calls from this number
sorry now let the games begin
[Music]
that's okay John very [ __ ] buddy man
[ __ ] fine do please get this thing off
my dick now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dude it's 6:00 in the holy [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] are you doing you didn't do this no
I didn't do this
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
jumble of pong we can't do that brother
but look because I'm using it right now
cuz it got you back [ __ ] you
yanked my dick off just remember one
thing Greg John has been a scare at
Halloween Horror Nights for the past two
years I looked at Halloween organized
for almost 10 years it's not funny
anymore man I'm the realest character
here and you meaningless
game over your hipster [ __ ] okay oh you
bet
[Music]
rats doing a week